it's my great pleasure to introduce
maria banner who
have done so much work in proof
complexity
on structural industrial instances for
sat
on bounded arithmetic and nowadays on
maxsat
i can't even um find
kind of one specific sentence to say
what you're working on because you're
doing so many things
so maria is in barcelona
uh uh upc barcelona
and um you know i'll just
let maria speak okay
thank you okay so well i'm going to
concentrate on a particular encoding
do already encoding and i'm going to
talk about
advantages and limitations um
and this is joint work with zambas
alexey
silva and antonio morgado okay
so um
well uh basically the motivation
is okay so such solvers are very
important because many problems can be
encoded into them
and uh but in general sad
is a very difficult problem to solve but
you know some industrial problems are
solved very
quickly but not some
other problems okay and we don't have
good tools for things for
instances like for instance the
pigeonhole principle and
other problems like that okay and also
um well
people are trying to develop like
solvers based you know different than
the ones based in conflict-driven class
learning
uh maybe to complement this type of
solvers
you know so that they can solve other
types of instances
and they're trying to see if stronger
systems then
resolution can and not too strong
otherwise it would be hard to find um
say
refutations uh
stronger systems than resolution to
[Music]
to solve some difficult problems okay
so okay this this is basically
the motivation okay so ignatieff
and uh silva and morgado
okay uh thought of the approach of
doing the following encoding okay
so i don't know why they called it dual
trail
okay but um basically
they they take a formula that they want
to know
uh they want to approve for instance
unsatisfiability
they encode it and they transform it
into a maxsat
problem okay and they solve it with some
maxset tool
okay so there are good things about
these uh
encodings well they're polynomial size
we can use max algorithms like
core guided or minimum heating set etc
okay that are already implemented
and and we can solve hard problems that
we cannot solve with
uh resolution or
cdcl um sat solvers
okay and i also want to talk a little
bit about what the power is of this dual
rail max
technique compared to other proof
systems but the main
uh the main objective today is talk
about encoding so that will be the
center of the talk okay
so um we're going to use partial magsat
okay so we need to give weights to the
clauses
uh and then weights indicate the cost of
falsifying a clause
we're going to partition the clauses
into soft and hard
the soft are the ones that we may
falsify
if we have to and the heart clusters are
the ones that
we must satisfy
so sub clauses in our case will have
weight
one okay so if some subclass
at some point must be falsified then
that will have the penalty of one and
the heart losses
may not be falsified and and we have
like a weight of infinity for instance
okay
so partial maxi is the problem of
finding an assignment
uh for a formula that satisfies all the
heart clauses and minimizes the number
of
falsified soft clauses okay
so this is the definition of the of the
dual rail encoding okay so our formula
originally has
variables x1 to s okay
and we're going to encode it with a
different set of variables
okay so we're going to have variables n
and 1 to n s for instance and p 1 p
sub s so the meaning of
n means that the variable is negative
and the minimum of p is that it's
positive okay so p
i is true if and only x is true that's
the meaning and
ni is true if and only if x i is false
so
p for positive and n for negative
okay so um we're gonna take our set of
clauses
okay and translate the following way so
whenever we see
an unnegated a positive variable x i
we're gonna substitute it for not and i
so it's not positive no it's not
negative
excuse me and if we have x negated
then we translate it by we substitute it
by p i
negated which means it's not positive
so for instance if we have x1
or not x3 or x4 it gets translated
into not n1 because
n1 x1 is not negative not p3
because um 3 is not
positive and not n4 because
um x4
is not negative it's positive okay
so the translation of these clauses
we see that all the variables are
negated here
this will be a not very nice clause for
us
when we see implementations because it
mixes ns and b's okay we will talk about
that later
okay so what else do we do so
we um translate the clauses the way i
said
okay and these clauses will be heart
clauses
okay then we'll have another set of
heart clauses which are the ones that
say a class can a variable cannot be
positive and negative
not positive or not negative okay
and um and finally we have
a set of soft clauses that are unique
clauses which are
you know p1
up to ps and n1 up to ns so we have
two times s subclasses okay
so what are we gonna do with this okay
so
be sure that uh our original set of uh
clauses is
satisfiable if and only there is an
assignment that satisfies
all the heart clauses of the translation
and end of the soft classes
which means um
so the you know an
assignment okay for the set of clauses
is a set
of the clauses some of the clauses some
of the literals excuse me are positive
some of the literals are negative
so um if we add the
the number of falsifies n's and b
is basically s is the form if the
formula is satisfiable okay
so if this set of original clauses is
unsatisfiable
okay then
[Music]
every assignment that satisfies all the
hard clauses
must falsify n plus one
or n plus one sub clauses here the n is
confusing
while i was using s so the original
number of
liter of variables which was s
previously
plus one okay so basically we're saying
um well that we cannot
find an assignment a coherent assignment
for the
for the original variables okay so uh
proving and satisfiability okay will
turn into a
a partial max sub problem because we
have a set of heart losses
a set of sub clauses okay and
we must obtain now a set of
empty clauses which corresponds to the
number of
original variables plus one okay
all right so here's an example
okay we have the pigeonhole principle
um which we all know okay we cannot
uh map in a one-to-one way n plus one
pigeons into one horse so we have two
types of clauses
okay the clauses that say that every
pigeon must fly some place which is a
disjunction
so pigeon i must fly to one of the end
halls
and then here we're saying
that not two pigeons can fly into the
same hole so
either not i the pigeon eye doesn't fly
to j
or the [ __ ] on k doesn't apply to j j
for um
for i n k pigeons and in this case would
be
j halls and j is in which is missing
here
okay so we know that this principle
has polynomial size reputations in frag
extended
in cutting planes but it's hard for
resolution and in fact
this is one of the principles where the
solvers fail
very badly okay so when we translate it
okay into this dual rail
way okay we have the variables positive
here
so now we have that we're saying they're
not negative so we have
n literals here saying that pigeon i for
instance goes
goes to somehow okay so here i only have
n variables and in the whole
clauses i have the p variables because
uh those were negative so
they're not positive right the p means
positive so they're not positive
so i have all my literals here negated
and i can see that here with the pigeon
clauses
all i'm using is the n variables and
here in the whole clauses all i'm using
are the p
variables okay so these
turn into hard clauses and then i have
the nijs and the pijs
okay um which will be
the soft um classes okay
so how many empty clauses do i need or
how many soft clauses do i need to
falsify which is equivalent
okay well the number of original
variables which was
n plus one times n plus one okay so this
is the number of subs
clauses that i need that i will show
that i need to have
to falsify or the number of empty
clauses that i need to produce
okay so
what is the general strategy so i'm i
prepared this talk in a different way as
previously
you know i wanted to give you an idea
for why
this was working in um
for some principles and what made other
principles
hard for this strategy okay
so here i'm just giving you the
pigeonhole principle again
but um more spelled out somehow okay so
here we have the pigeon one
has to fly somewhere okay
and these are the variable the end
variables
that have to do with pigeon one and
here okay so they're the same clauses
for
all the other pigeons up to the last one
so the pitch on n plus one
n plus well there's n sub n i'm sorry
about this but
i you know pigeonhole principle always
do n plus one into n and
you know i have n meaning negated
variable and
it's really bad notation but i hope you
don't get
too confused okay so we're saying that
the pitch on n plus one
has to fly somewhere okay
and here are the soft clauses okay
and here i divided the the whole clauses
into the ones that
talk about the whole one up to the ones
that talk about
the whole end okay the heart clauses
and the soft clauses okay this is the
set of heart clauses saying that only
one pigeon basically flies at most flies
into hole one and this last one would be
or
you know that at most one picture will
fly into the whole end
so why am i giving you the pigeon hole
principle in this shape
well because what i want to show you is
that
um here the variables are it's like i
broken the problem into pieces that have
independent variables disjoined
variables okay
so here i have the variables that talk
about pigeon one
and the variable n up to you know in
each one of these pieces you know i have
for instance here
all the variables that i'm using in this
part are the variables that talk about n
variables in the pigeon n plus one
okay here i have uh the
um whole variables which are p variables
okay
and in this case i only talk about the
whole
one and so on okay so do you see how
i've broken the problem into pieces
that have disjoined variables okay so i
could solve these problems
separately right and
this is one thing that i can do because
i have these two sets of variables
and and i don't need to obtain
proof of unsatisfiability just a second
i don't need these clauses
okay these clauses are very confusing
and uh not good for or when we use them
in the implementations they slow things
very much because they mix p and n
variables
okay and what we're trying to do or what
is interesting about this encoding is
that we can
it helps us break the problem into
pieces with this joint variable so
solve a bunch of smaller problems rather
than one big problem
okay and i think
this idea maybe somebody can think of
generalizing modifying whatever
something
with it i don't know okay so how do we
prove that the pigeonhole principle is
unsatisfiable
okay so we must prove um
uh false uh n times n plus one plus one
soft clauses okay so
in for each one of the pigeons we can
generate uh
um satisfiability because here we're
saying one of this has to be
false and here we're saying that all of
them are true basically so we have
an empty clause say um in each one
of these n plus one groups okay
and here uh basically we have the p
clauses
for say whole one and
here we're saying that at most uh one
pigeon goes into whole one
right so they said okay
uh should produce um n uh
on certain you know empty classes or
whatever or in
subclasses false you know
because it's at most one of them that
has to be true
right so what do we get for the first
four division clauses we get n plus one
falses okay and for the whole clauses we
have
n sets each one of them generates n
falses
right if we add this up then we get
you know the numbers that we want right
so this is the general strategy but what
do we do
so we encode okay so
using these two types of variables we
separate
um well we we in this case we separated
the pigeon clauses from the whole
clauses very nicely
uh we have this disjoint variables we
try to solve them
the problems independently okay
and um and then
i will talk about the disadvantages in a
minute so then what do we do
after we break the formline pieces okay
well uh we can use max hat resolution
which i will define shortly to obtain a
total of
the number of original variables plus
one empty clauses
or i can use any algorithm for max add
like core guided
okay or minimum heating set algorithms
etc
okay and try to solve this independent
this pieces okay so what is the
disadvantage you know
the disadvantage is that okay when we
mix the
negative and the positive variables
things get very difficult
um and it slows us down
very much right in fact for many
the problems that we've encoded and
we've done experimentation on
um if we could um
okay when we could encode the clauses
so that i we only had either p variables
or n variables
okay we usually did need this uh
this um clauses okay so we could
eliminate them and that made our
experimentation
much faster okay because they were not
necessary
okay so how much time do i have until
now
um about three minutes five minutes
okay so i don't know
okay uh
well as i said you know you encode the
formula
with this in this other language and you
transform a satisfiability problem into
a
partial head problem and one of the
tools that you can use is max hat
resolution
right so this is a rule that is um
sound and complete for maxat okay and
um an important characteristic of this
rule is that
you don't add clauses but you substitute
clauses for instance
here okay so i have x or a
with weight one it's a subclause and not
x of b with weight one
and i substitute these two clauses so i
eliminate them and i introduce a or b
with weight one
and a collection of uh weakenings
of the initial clauses so i lost
the original clauses okay but i gained
the
the the cut okay and some
weakenings okay this is a set of clauses
but let's not bother with it now
and we can do it with uh soft and hard
clauses etc
okay so
um well this is an example but
there it in general solvers don't use
don't use
the max ad rule is like you know solvers
for sad don't use resolution per se
right um i think there's a
solver that is called eva or something
like that that uses some form of
maximum resolution but i'm not sure
about how much of it
okay then there are other algorithms to
solve
um maxad okay
that uh rely on iterative calls to sat
solvers
okay and uh and i have a
an important point to make about maximum
resolution okay
if we don't use if we don't use the
the dual rail encoding okay before
doing maxat inference okay pigeonhole
principle is hard there are
lower bounds so if you don't encode
so if you use the original variables in
the original
encoding for instance for the pigeonhole
principle or anything that is hard for
resolution
basically you know using the max rule
okay obviously it's not gonna help okay
there are lower bounds
they're very easy to prove okay
but with the dual rail encoding
uh we can do a lot more okay
so back to the core guided algorithm
so what do we do
[Music]
uh well this is uh an algorithm based on
iterative calls to assad solver and
where
um here i don't want to explain the
details because i don't have much time i
want to
just say a little bit about other things
but here this lambda
so we have a working formula um with
soft and hard clauses the lambda
is how many soft clauses we must
make unsatisfiable okay and
uh when we call the sat solver it says
or unsat if it says sad then we output
a satisfying assignment but we already
we have also
um a lower bound a number of soft
classes that must be falsified
but but if it doesn't say sad okay
we reconstruct the formula okay
we augment the number of uh subclauses
that must be false
okay and
[Music]
introduce substitute some clauses
by others with uh first variables and we
have this
[Music]
encoding of how many of them
[Music]
basically here we're just needing an
upper bound you know we're saying okay
i let you falsify one more soft class
but no more see what you can do now okay
what okay so we can use
this sort of algorithms okay but i
wanted just to
say very quickly so where does this rule
dual rail max add okay uh
lie within other you know uh
positional group systems right so
multiple dual rail max add which means
that you might
have several copies of the soft
unit clauses okay but then you need to
get more empty clauses okay
this simulates three like resolution if
we make it weighted
okay so you can have uh many
uh an exponential number say uh encoded
in binary um
soft clauses and then need to generate
many more
empty clauses then you can a simulate
general resolution
okay and we don't know how to do it
better than this
so we use dual raymax with the core
guided algorithm then we can simulate
resolution
easily okay so i'm not gonna define the
parity principle well i'm just gonna say
what it is okay
so we have a graph with an odd number of
vertices and we're saying that
it's not possible to have uh every
vertex with degree one
okay so
okay so what did we prove about this
um well so we showed also that accuracy
bounded the frigate
plus the pigeonhole principle scheme
he simulates dual red maxsat okay
and um we also know that
acc oops sorry we know that ac zero
frigate plus the bingen whole principle
um okay it requires
exponential size to refute the parity
principle
okay so um
so that means that here we have like a a
lower bound for the max set
resolution with the dual rail which
means that
we require exponential size with the
parity principle
okay
this is with the with max resolution
okay and as a corollary we obtained that
dual rail max sat proof systems do not
polynomially stimulate
cutting planes because they can do the
party principle
efficiently okay but
it's funny that we can show
theoretically and
also with experimentation that we if we
use the
minimum heating set algorithm uh
with the dual rail max at encoding and
then
we we have efficient refutations of the
of the party principle um
well i think i'm just oops
i guess i'm out of the time i don't know
antonina i just said three minutes but
i wanted to show some of the
experimentation but
please do please show
excuse me let's make it into a question
can you show us the experiments
okay i just i mean i had experiments in
some other places but
this is okay and i didn't define it this
is uh
the double i just took one one
graphic you know for the double
pigeonhole principle
the reason i did this is because it's
harder for than the pigeonhole principle
it's also difficult for a solution
obviously okay
we have two m plus one pigeons and m
holes
and we say that we cannot
place them with at most two
pigeons in one hole okay
and so this
this pigeonhole principle this double
pigeonhole principle for instance
we can we can show repetitions
efficiently
with um with uh the dual brain max ah
resolution okay
and uh here we see let's see we have we
did experimentation with a bunch of
solvers
the first thing that i need to tell you
is that this
ones that have the prime it means that
they don't have the clauses that makes
the ps
and the end variables when we say that
not bi or not
ni okay which we don't need
to do the refutation okay so if we
eliminate those clauses
then we get um
much faster results you know
uh then then when we
leave the the
the not pi or not ni clauses okay so
there's a huge difference
in the size of the instances that we can
solve okay
and uh here below we have
um sad
basic sad algorithm
[Music]
conflict-driven class learning this is
max at um
so these are mixed of sat and max hat
tools okay but with the
and these are these are here with the
clauses that mix the
piece and dance and these are the
results
for basically um core guided
eva is the one that i think has the the
max ad resolution
okay but with the dual rail these are
minimum heating set
this and this etc so what we see here is
that
if we use um sat algorithms
there's no chance we can solve these
instances
if we use the dual rail um
and any algorithm but we leave the
clauses that mix the ends and the piece
we don't get
good results either we get good results
when
when we eliminate those clauses that mix
the ends and the ps
okay and use the
the dual braille encoding with the with
the tools
to solve partial magsat basically
you know this is just an example
[Music]
that's it
thank you so much
so questions comments did you
check did you check how does it scale as
a function of
m oh did you check how does it well it's
just
so distorted that it's hard to hear
right
how does it scale how does it scale as a
function of
m
as a function of m yeah yeah you're
showing just instance number
but here you can actually generate
instances where
with increasing m and how does it scale
as a function of
m well your best solver i mean how does
it scale
yeah i suppose it would show a similar
i don't know i mean we haven't done that
experimentation but i
suppose why do you think it would show
some you know
show something more or extra well
because one of the things for example
are we
do the whole scale exponentially but
with different exponents
okay on different bases if you want of
the exponential
you'll see to the end but with a smaller
c so it's not i mean there is a dramatic
difference between your boss your best
performing and your was performing
yes and scalability would at least tell
us
is you know are we are we what are we
improving here
are we improving it in a multiplicative
way are we proving it in an exponential
way
is number of instances is it is it the
same as m
what is it the same as m i didn't
understand the last
bit you know number of instances
number of instances because you can just
you can just
you can just kind of take the problem
and generate commute it randomly it's
another way to generate more instances
so um i've got a separate question
um you know at some level this you're
counting
the number of falsified uh
number number of true literals that you
require number of falsified literals
you're
doing a count of that relative to the
total number of
of uh variables um which is sort of
you know gives that intuition so it's
actually surprising what do you have any
intuition as to
what your what your system is doing
outside of ac zero fraga
things and there's some form of
reduction to a pigeonhole principle like
property going on do you have an
intuition of how with
maximum hitting set you're actually uh
you're getting around that
well maximum heating said it's a whole
different story for me you know
because uh
you know i mean your calling
is like the the sad solver it's played
to the minimum
and what really plays a role there is
the
the calculation of minimum heating set
okay
and i guess this solver is yours
what is it called uh
simplex or things like this right
i wanna i wanna turn off turn this off
so that i can see the faces of people
you know and i don't know how to do it
you know oh no no
just a second i'm gonna minimize it
because
i'm talking to the guys and unshare
unshares where you're going to get your
system yeah
[Music]
stop sharing the red whatever is red on
your
scary yeah okay now i couldn't see who i
was talking
to okay so who was asking me a question
yeah it was it was
going to see something
so before was moshe and now no it's now
it's me
okay paul now i see you okay yes
okay again yeah
[Music]
so yeah so the right so the the
the thing is is is it because
you know getting set is this very hard
problem and you're assuming that you
you know for that polynomial time that
you actually are getting a solution to
that
potentially hard problem or uh is that
why you're getting
polynomial time i mean it's just
surprising that it's sort of going
beyond
what an ac zero fraga essentially
reduction in some sense to uh original
principle or is there something else
yeah the thing is that when you use
these encodings
uh and and you see when you're breaking
the problem
into these you know it's like the the
unsatisfiable course
are very easy to obtain and and then
everything is played in the finding of
the minimum heating
sets you know and using other tools that
have nothing to do with uh say
resolution or
i see i show oh sure yeah of course
makes sense yep
i also ask a quick question um so it
seems to me
that it's hard to
to combine you to combine your approach
with this modeling you understand what i
mean namely um so you're sorting is now
like a big problem
we wanted to solve the picture of
problems but nobody's interested in
solving the picture
probably we know what it's true for well
not necessarily not only the pigeonhole
principle you know but i was thinking um
so of this modeling so in modeling
pigeonhole from pigeon performers are
used
injectivity search activity all
different constraints
and and the light so it's quite you
actually quite use them
but now with your approach it seems to
be at the moment at least very intrusive
you had to reformulate the whole your
whole sub problem
if you just want to use this little
pigeonhole formula in it
and so that seems to be quite a
stumbling block for uh for
you have to use a maxad solvent
reformulate the whole your whole problem
into
that formula as it seems to me
some thoughts on that or yeah but
yeah but as i said you know i mean in
the cases
where i have clauses that only have
either positive or
negative literals you know like
even parity you know even though we
cannot do it with a core guided
algorithms
efficiently so far we don't know how to
do it
but i think subset cardinality also has
the same shape so we don't when we don't
mix positive and negative you know uh
and we managed to break the problem into
this um
some formulas that have uh these joint
variables you know it
it helps right um
i don't know maybe some people have an
idea of how when you mix
variables how to do it so that re encode
so that this doesn't happen i don't know
i mean
i don't know it has this limitation
the the the method right
but um it works
for some principles you know thank you
okay thank you very very much marie and